a protest happening right now where
group is demanding changes after a
recent video showed a CCSD police
officer having a rough altercation with
a student Joshua baguero has been there
throughout the afternoon and has an
update for us Joshua
more people continue showing up to this
protest right now I'm a step out of the
way so you can get a look at the crowd
again it's continuing to increase minute
by minute you have people here from
different races ethnicities ages as well
from young children to much more older
adults again they're calling for the
firing of that police officer this is at
the Clark County School District
Administrative Building and as you can
see they're having it on the sidewalk
because they were barred from holding
this protest and rally in front of the
administrative building but again
they're just they're again upset that
the fact that this teenager black youth
was taken down by the police officer and
the police officer was reassigned and
not fired we're going to continue being
at this protest and continuing to
monitoring it and we will bring you some
more at 6 30. reporting live Joshua
paguero eight news now